Here I am I love this city I'm just so  impressed by the energy here and there's  only one example they're organizing some  kind of an environmental display here  demonstrations about  there's just a sense of freedom and  activity and effervescence in this  quite stimulating earlier  this is the square of the city hall  right behind me is the sole City Hall  people are friendly  book stores that i visited  get back here  at least I hope  organizers who explained there are we go  ok looks  there you go one on your on your name  good it's all gone no harmoo burro  amoroso know what don't oh darling son  what time is our necks on your head yeah  my eyes okay thank you yoga's ho that's  all you let me down to marry totally  without she's all cutting a day off how  r Patterson oh she be mirga's in with a  clade on a glass Joshua he told me so no  hey Jesus or Canada so I didn't fully  understand it but it has to do with the  environment and its young and full of  life so there you have it